-And here's how this works
We have a bunch of random
objects on the stands behind us.
We have not seen them.
Some are very heavy,
while some are very light.
Looks can be deceiving.
On your turn,
you pick up an object
and carry it across the stage.
Your opponents will watch you.
And then they must come
to a unanimous decision.
Is it heavy?
Or light, light, light?
[ Light laughter ]
Then you'll toss the objec
onto this Weight-O-Meter.
If it goes through the paper
it's heavy.
If not, it's light, light,
light, light.
[ Light laughter ]
I'll go first.
You guys hang out over there
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Heavy or light?
Here we go.
[ Whistling ]
♪♪♪♪
-Light.
It's light.
[ Grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Are you okay, man?
-[ Grunting ]
-Oh, man --
-Whoa. Ah --
-What do you guys think?
-If it's heavy --
-Is it heavy or is it light?
-Light!
-I -- I think you're pretendin
that it's heavy.
-It's light.
-But it's light.
-Yes.
-But it might be heavier
than we think.
So, I still think it's heavy
[ Crashing ]
-All right, it's very heavy.
Yeah.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-That's --
that's a whole tree.
[ Laughter ]
-It's actually too heavy,
actually.
-That's too heavy.
-That was really heavy for me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Ken, now it is your turn.
-Oh, enchanté.
Okay, here I go.
All right, great, great.
-Goodness, that was
too heavy for me.
-Okay --
[ Clapping ]
Okay.
-You guys can clap along
if you want.
-Okay.
[ Clapping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
-Wait, I think --
-Oh, I think it's real popcorn
-No, I think he's acting
like it's light,
but I feel like it's heavy
-I'm a weak man, Jimmy.
I can't --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
-Wow.
-I don't know it.
-What, what do you think?
-♪♪ I'm going to the movies
-He's a really good actor.
[ Laughter ]
-Oooh.
-Cool.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's light.
-Heavy or light?
-Light.
-I say light as well.
-All right.
[ Crashing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone ]
-Why did you listen to me?
-I listened to you.
-You're the one who did
it to me!
[ Laughter ]
Gosh!
Of course it was heavy.
You're a good actor.
Very, very nice man.
You're almost a little
bit too dancy with it.
-Yeah.
-I thought maybe that's a --
all right.
-You're so strong.
-It's your turn, Kate.
-Okay.
-Go for it. Sorry, bud.
I mean, that was fantastic
-Thanks, bro.
-You're in the lead.
[ Cheers ]
[ Clapping ]
-Let's see.
-♪♪ Heavy or light ♪♪
♪♪ Heavy or light ♪♪
♪♪ heavy or light ♪♪
-♪♪ Kate Upton, is that
heavy or light ♪♪
-I think it's light.
I think it's light.
-Really?
-I'm a doctor, dude.
I know what I'm saying.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-It's light.
[ Crashing ]
[ Sad trombone ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-See what I'm saying?
-Yep, yep.
-He's a doctor.
-No, no.
I should correct that.
I was a doctor.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I'm not anymore.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
-It is time for the final round.
Ken and I are going
to go together.
-Okay.
-Carry the same object.
-All right.
-Kate will have to guess.
This one is worth 3,967 points
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah, this is for the game.
-Dude!
-Yeah, whoever wins this.
Either we win or Kate loses.
-I thought this was only -
-Fun?
-It's just for fun.
Yeah, I don't understand.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-All right.
Oh, God. I don't know.
-I don't --
[ Clapping ]
-Okay, maybe this.
-One, two, three.
-Oh, dude.
[ Clapping ]
-Ugh.
-Oh, no.
-All right, dude. Don't --
-My heart is literally racing.
I want to win so bad.
♪♪♪♪
Uh!
-Heavy or light?
-What do you guys think?
-Light!
-Light?
-Light! Light!
-I think it's light.
I think it's light.
-One, two, three.
[ Light crash ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ]
[ Sad trombone ]
-Kate Upton, everybody!
Kate, come on over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic!
-Thank you.
-Ken Jeong, Kate Upton.
That was, "Heavy or Light.
-Wow.
-If you're just tuning in that
was, "Heavy or Light."
We're talking with Ken
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's crazy, man!
That's crazy!